dix morts 43 blessées dans une explosion
en irlande du nord londres accusent les
terroristes de l'ira tunisie c'est le
calme 24 heures après la passation de
pouvoir forcée de l'ex président habib
bourguiba en italie les juges auront
peut-être à répondre devant la justice
de leur erreur la réponse dépend d'un
référendum qui a lieu aujourd'hui une
journée supplémentaire de détention pour
marcel carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés
madame monsieur bonsoir encore plus que
le liban le conflit d'irlande du nord
nous semble remonter jusque dans la nuit
des temps et pourtant régulièrement et
dramatiquement
il se rappelle à notre mémoire
aujourd'hui l'explosion d'une bombe a
fait 10 morts et 43 blessés dans une
localité du sud-ouest de la province
l'engin a explosé au beau milieu d'une
cérémonie anniversaire de l'armistice de
la première guerre mondiale
c'est l'un des attentats les plus
meurtriers de l'histoire tragique de
cette guerre civile interminable et bien
qu'il n'ait pas encore été revendiqué
les autorités britanniques attribuent
cet attentat aux terroristes de l'ira
philippe harbart ces images ont été pris
par un amateur immédiatement après
l'explosion vernis la bombe était
dissimulée dans une ancienne école à
côté du monument aux morts à ahnif
silène où se déroulait comme partout une
cérémonie du souvenir à la mémoire des
victimes de la grande guerre
presque tout le village était rassemblée
ce qui explique le nombre élevé de
victimes dix morts dont quatre femmes
plus de 40 blessés parmi lesquels des
enfants
les autorités ont immédiatement
soupçonné lira d'avoir commis l'attentât
volontairement meurtrier pourquoi à eni
silène peut-être parce que cette petite
cité du holland du nord abritent un des
régimes les plus anciens de la province
la reine qui à londres présidé la
cérémonie officielle du souvenir a fait
part de sa vive émotion en apprenant
l'attentât margaret thatcher très choqué
a qualifié cet acte de complètement
barbares acte qui frappe la population
civile d'un village le jour même
elle se souvient de ceux qui se sont
sacrifiés pour leur patrie l'ira
pourrait bien avoir voulu se venger de
ses récents revers
le dernier en date étant la saisie
d'armes en france et l'arrestation de
cinq hommes dont au moins un des chefs
de l'organisation terroriste
en principe les rats ne s'attaque qu'aux
personnalités politiques ou aux cibles
militaires mais il ya au sein de
l'organisation terroriste des groupes
extrémistes prêt à frapper n'importe où
et n'importe quand ce sont eux qui
avaient commis l'attentât contre le
magasin harrods il ya quatre ans qui
avait fait huit morts
ce sont peut être eux qui ont frappé ce
matin à enis killen si c'est le cas cela
montrerait que les extrémistes ont
repris le dessus à l'ira et cela
n'augure rien de bon
une dépêche que je vous livre tout de
suite mais sous toute réserve au
conditionnel donc le groupe terroriste
palestinien abou nidal annonce qu'il a
arraisonné au large de la bande de gaza
un navire battant double pavillon
israélien et belge et à bord duquel se
trouvent huit passagers qui ont été pris
en otage c'est pas ça des passagers
pardon possède aussi une double
nationalité belge et israéliennes et
françaises
israël pour l'instant l'armée
israélienne déclare tout ignorer de
cette affaire et le ministère des
affaires étrangères à paris ne fait
aucun commentaire tunisie c'est le calme
24 heures après que le président
bourguiba et été démis de ses fonctions
pour raisons de santé comme l'a affirmé
son successeur l'ancien premier ministre
monsieur bnl
ce soir notre envoyé spécial jacques
merlino en a appris un peu plus sur la
manière dont cette s'est déroulée cette
passation de pouvoir un peu forcé mais
en douceur jusqu'à présent à peine
quelques heures après l'éviction du
président bourguiba déjà les murs de
tunis se couvre la fiche à la gloire du
nouveau président dans le même temps les
paroles de l'hymne national ont été
changés et sa diffusion à la télévision
ne fait plus mention du combattant
suprême
ces deux détails et bien d'autres
montrent avec quel soin l'opération
changement de président fut bien préparé
cela montre aussi que la réalité est
peut être beaucoup plus complexe pour ne
la justice
ils essaient entendre en fait selon nos
informations le président bourguiba déçu
par les condamnations mesurer lors du
récent procès les intégristes se
préparaient à mettre fin aux fonctions
de son premier ministre celui ci
monsieur ben ali aurait pris les devants
et pour éviter d'être destitué aurait ta
vie est invoqué la sénilité du président
bourguiba
c'est pour cela que l'on entend de plus
en plus ici l'expression coup d'état
blanc pour caractériser cette prise de
pouvoir en douceur et sous un habillage
constitutionnel il est vrai que chacun
savait que le successeur de bourguiba
serait le premier ministre en exercice
le jour de la mort du président
si monsieur ben ali était effectivement
menacée d'être limogé il était important
pour lui d'agir vite
depuis quelques années le président
bourguiba vieillissant se refusant à
préparer sa succession avait fait le
vide autour de lui et il laisse son pays
quelconque quelles que soient ses
mérites antérieures qui sont importants
il laisse donc son pays dans une
situation politique et économique pour
le moins ils ont des lic et bon nombre
de tunisiens pensent que ce retrait
d'habib bourguiba peut débloquer
beaucoup de choses en tunisie à
condition à condition que le nouveau
président agisse vite très vite
jérôme benest le président bourguiba qui
a fait de la tunisie une nation la
stabilité politique exemplaire laisse
aussi à son héritier un passif lourd
économie fragile reposant sur le
tourisme chômage trois cent mille
tunisiens sont sans emploi 14% de la
population
j'ai trois enfants des garçons nus comme
à la naissance explique ce chômeur je
les enferme à la maison pour que les
gens ne se moque pas d'eux presse
censurée dont les trois journaux
reproduisez quotidiennement à la une les
mêmes photo protocolaire du président
scène politique et sociale déserte
les dernières élections législatives en
novembre 86 furent boycotté par les
partis de l'opposition dénonçant la
fraude
le principal syndicat juge et été
neutralisée sous les yeux d'un leader de
l'opposition
et hege par la police a donné l'assaut
beaucoup de lui et des piscines
ce vide politique favorise l'émergence
ces dernières années d'un mouvement
islamique clandestins renforcée par une
répression sévère
le mt y seul encore capable de mobiliser
la population dans les universités les
mosquées et les quartiers pauvres
le nouveau président vient d'annoncer un
projet de loi sur la presse et les
partis politiques
mais il va se heurter au tout-puissant
parti socialiste destourien encore au
pouvoir libérer de l'emprise d'un
bourguiba diminué moralement et
physiquement
son successeur n'est pas prêt pour
autant d' effacer la marque sur la
tunisie de 31 ans de présidence du
combattant suprême
c'est un sommet arabe qui pourrait
aboutir à des résultats qui vient de
s'ouvrir à amman en jordanie
en effet excepté l'egypte toujours
boycotté depuis son accord de paix avec
israël
tous les pays arabes importance sont
présents même les frères ennemis le
syrien assad et l'irakien saddam hussein
et pour la première fois ce n'est pas le
problème palestinien qui domine mais le
conflit iran irak et dans son discours
d'ouverture le secrétaire général de la
ligue arabe
monsieur klibi demande aux nations unies
de prendre des sanctions contre l'iran
si celle ci n'accepte pas la résolution
de l'onu appelant à un cessez le feu
sans condition jean-marc il dans cette
partie de la capitale jordanienne
transformé en véritable no man's land
par près de dix mille soldats
la quasi-totalité des plus hauts
dirigeants de près de 215 millions
d'arabes a donc finalement répondu aux
patients appel du roi hussein de
jordanie
trois jours de débats à huis clos pour
tenter de nouveau de faire cause commune
mais cette fois ci l'enjeu prioritaire
n'est plus la lutte contre
l'expansionnisme israélien je cite mais
d'abord les dangers de la guerre irak
iran
une fois n'est pas coutume saddam
hussein le président irakien s'est
déplacé avec l'aide de son allié le roi
de jordanie et voudrait obtenir rien de
moins qu'un véritable pacte de défense
arabe contre l'iran mais son éternel
rival le président syrien hafez el-assad
ne l'entend pas de cette oreille
proche de l'iran il veut éviter à tout
prix que le conflit ne dégénère en une
véritable guerre entre arabes et perses
reste que pour la première fois depuis
longtemps les frères ennemis du monde
arabe se rencontreront publiquement ne
manque donc que l'egypte toujours exclus
de ce genre de réunion en raison de son
traité de paix avec israël l'egypte dont
le poids politique et militaire sera
pourtant bien présent tout au long des
débats le président de la république
populaire de chine en visite en france
dans les pays communistes le numéro un
c'est le secrétaire du parti monsieur
l'icsi à niang n'est donc pas très connu
mais n'est pas connu du tout à
l'étranger il est tout de même un
personnage relativement important dans
ce pays
compagnon de route de mao tsé toung il
est en chine le gardien de l'orthodoxie
du régime à 90 ans 81 2 ans par dont il
commence donc sa visite officielle
demain à paris mais avant il a voulu
connaître la côte d'azur le marché aux
mille fleurs de lotus de nice et ensuite
il s'est rendu dans le temple du cinéma
capitaliste à cannes
le palais des festivals
comme le voudraient certains hommes
politiques français comme cela se passe
déjà en suisse très couramment là bas
les italiens sont appelés aujourd'hui à
répondre à 5 questions dans un seul
référendum dont trois questions sur la
poursuite ou non du programme nucléaire
italien qui n'est pas très important il
faut le dire mais la plus importante
question concerne les magistrats les
juges d'instruction qui pourrait être en
italie
si les italiens répondent oui
responsable désormais à titre personnel
de leurs erreurs autrement dit le juge
jugé l'arroseur arrosé les principales
formations politiques démocratie
chrétienne et communistes appellent à
voter d'ailleurs dans ce sens c'est
important car les juges italiens ont été
au risque souvent de leur vie ces
dernières années les plus exposés sur le
front de la lutte contre la corruption
politique
la mafia et le terrorisme marcel trillât
un homme particulièrement amer sans
doute en ce jour de référendum le juge
d'instruction sicilien giovanni falcone
c'est lui qui a recueilli les
confessions du repenti bouchette avec
quatre confrères il a instruit le procès
des 474 mafiosi actuellement jugé à
palerme
giovanni falcone un héros du front anti
mafia mais aussi un homme seul traquer
un mort en sursis depuis 1972
quarante deux juges ont été assassinés
par lecture des brigades rouges ou ceux
de l'honorable société comme ici à
palerme le juge kenichi dans la guerre
sans merci contre ces deux fléaux qui
rongent et la démocratie italienne
ils ont été aux avant postes ils sont
aujourd'hui la cible principale de la
majorité des partis politiques
italiennes près de 46 millions
d'électeurs doivent répondre à cinq
questions sur l'arrêt du programme
nucléaire et sur la justice
une seule passionne les italiens les
juges devront ils oui ou non payés de
leurs propres deniers toute erreur
commise ou même toute erreur supposée
une menace que les magistrats unanimes
considèrent comme un désaveu
les uns à laval il est certain que la
magistrature sortira de cette épreuve
très mortifie après ces années de lutte
contre le terrorisme pendant lesquels la
magistrature italienne a payé de son
sang le prix de la liberté
après ces années pendant lesquelles les
juges ont été les fantassins qui
s'expose pour défendre la vie des
citoyens est clair que c'est une étrange
manière
il est vrai que les magistrats italiens
abuse parfois de leur énorme pouvoir
enzo tortora vedette de la télévision
accusé sur dénonciation de repentis de
complicité dans les trafics de drogue de
la camorra napolitaine fille trois ans
de prison avant que l'on se rende à
l'évidence le dossier était vide en
italie l'indépendance de la magistrature
et sans limites les juges du parquet
eux-mêmes ne dépendent pas comme en
france du ministre de la justice mais
seulement du conseil de la magistrature
tout puissant théoriquement du moins un
exemple en 1984 le juge palerme ont
instruit dans le nord de l'italie
une énorme affaire de trafic d'armes au
détour du dossier il découvre d'étranges
ramifications entre cette juteuse
affaire et les caisses de l'un des
principaux partis au pouvoir
il est hautement muté en sicile quelques
mois plus tard il échappe
miraculeusement un attentat attribué à
la mafia
une femme et ses deux enfants qui
passait là par hasard sont déchiquetés
depuis le juge palerme où se terre dans
un bureau de rome lui aussi doit être
amer aujourd'hui les partis politiques
qui appellent à voter oui dans leur
immense majorité souhaite il secrètement
réduire l'ensemble des juges à la même
impuissance c'est peut-être la seule
vraie question posée aux italiens par ce
référendum la nouvelle calédonie le face
à face entre gendarmes et un groupe
d'indépendantistes se poursuit dans la
banlieue de nouméa 48 heures après la
mort d'un jeune mélanésiens tué au cours
d'une opération de police vendredi
dernier
aujourd'hui près du barrage établi par
les indépendantistes un photographe a
été blessé véronique auger la tension
monte autour du village de la tribu de
saint louis
là où le jeune mélanésiens a été tué par
un gendarme vendre
les forces de l'ordre barre la route de
nouméa face à eux
plusieurs barrages de jeunes kanaks
armée vendredi deux gendarmes ont été
légèrement blessés samedi
c'est un photographe qui a reçu un
projectile il circulait dans la voiture
de rfo les jeunes mélanésiens qui semble
de moins en moins obéissant aux conseils
de prudence des leader kanak refuse de
bouger tant qu'ils n'auront pas reçu
l'assurance qu'aucune poursuite
judiciaire ne sera engagée contre eux
une partie du fln caisse se réunit à la
fin de la semaine
question à l'ordre du jour les
indépendantistes doivent-ils ou non
abandonner leur stratégie de non
violence
quoi qu'il en soit la situation restera
explosif jusqu'au 23 novembre date du
débat à l'assemblée nationale sur le
statut de la nouvelle calédonie oui dans
un communiqué publié aujourd'hui
monsieur georges sarre du parti
socialiste estime que sans perspective
d'autonomie pour le territoire
on s'achemine tout doucement ou plus
rapidement vers une situation explosive
tout au long de ce week end majorité et
extrême droite se sont répondu par
déclarations interposées
les socialistes au milieu se place en
arbitre laurent boussier jean marie le
pen front national le puits dire que je
n'ai aucun souci en ce qui concerne
la quête des des signatures de maires
que j'en ai plus de cinq cents 500
signatures pour jean marie le pen mais
hier soir jacques chirac a réaffirmé son
attitude vis-à-vis de l'extrême droite
pour ma part je ne contracterait jamais
d'alliance ni à titre personnel ni en
tant que responsable d'un mouvement
politique avec tel ou tel parti
d'extrême droite dont les valeurs les
idées qu'elles soient volontairement
afficher ou échappé du subconscient ne
sont pas celles du gaullisme et me
semble contraire non seulement aux
traditions et à l'esprit mais même aux
intérêts profonds de notre pays
jacques chirac critiqué par georges
sarre député socialiste de paris qui
accusent le premier ministre de double
langage politique paris dit il doit être
classé parmi les trois villes de france
où le rpr et l'udf se sont associés au
front national
et puis ce week-end encore monsieur le
pen que vous venez d'entendre rice a
également exposé la politique sociale de
son parti le front national pour lui les
allocations familiales doivent être
réservés aux nationaux c'est à dire aux
français de nationalité et la retraite
l'indemnité chômage payées à tout le
monde mais au niveau du salaire minimum
le smic
enfin il propose un tarif variés qui
doit être établi pour les remboursements
de la sécurité sociale
conséquence d'un affrontement cours mais
violents entre policiers et manifestants
du parti communiste et de la cgt
vendredi dernier à amiens un manifestant
dans le coma et un policier plus
légèrement blessés vos enfants se
conduiront dans la vie comme ils le
pourront certains comme ils le voudront
en revanche ils conduiront peut-être
leur voiture comme ils l'auront vu faire
par leurs parents ou comme ils l'auront
appris et c'est possible maintenant très
tôt grâce à une école de conduite pour
enfants qui vient de s'ouvrir
valérie fournier
non la vitesse ne s'apprend pas ici et
puis 15 20 km heure pour un enfant c'est
déjà beaucoup de vraies voitures
équipées d'un moteur à essence au
plancher les trois pédales classique
rien à voir avec le vélo ça chauffe le
pivot
fois qu'on aura bien expliquer que c'est
pas la vitesse qui peut mondial 10 ans
prennent bien conscience
après ils préfèrent être techniquement
bons conducteurs que les des pilotes de
course je lâche la [ __ ]
il ya je ne
clap avant la pratique la technique et
la théorie la leçon au coût de 45 francs
un prix variable selon le niveau de
l'enfant cette première école de
conduite s'attache alors à prendre la
sécurité et à les rendre responsables
voulons effectivement lui donner une
expérience vécue nous permettant
d'apprendre plus facilement à conduire
et auprès fracture mais là moment venu
véritable outil pédagogique et ludique
pour devenir un parfait futurs
automobilistes avec toutes les
contraintes que cela implique
c'est un tout autre sport que s'est
livré cette semaine gérard pas bio la
bricole il a visité le salon du
bricolage à paris et autant que
nouveauté il s'est intéressé aux
conséquences du maniement hebdomadaire
du marteau ou de la perceuse
le salon du bricolage 22e du genre c'est
chaque année de nouveaux adeptes la
preuve on ne compte plus ceux qui le
pratiquent mais ceux qui n'en font pas
encore les irréductibles
tenez vous bien ils ne sont plus que 6 %
à bouder ce sport dominical même les
femmes s'y adonnent enfin surtout pour
donner leur avis puisque 90% des achats
sont motivés par elle alors parmi les
bricoleurs il y à différentes catégories
celui qui veut faire mais qui ne sait
pas comment s'y prendre celui qui ne
veut pas mais qui cherchent à savoir
comment ça marche et enfin celui qui
découvre qu'il a encore bien des progrès
à faire
les grands thèmes du salon 87 sont la
sécurité et le gain de place lequel
s'étend sur un étage tout entier s'est
souvent pratiques ingénieux voire
impératif ont tenu de l'exiguïté des
logements actuels mais encore faut-il en
connaître parfaitement le mode d'emploi
le bricolage n'est plus seulement une
passion il devient une nécessité
économique
mais il peut aussi coûter cher et c'est
ce que nous indique la sécurité sociale
également présente au salon ça c'est une
nouveauté elle nous apprend les dangers
de l'amateurisme les incendies dans les
cuisines par exemple qu'en le voyant des
plaques chauffantes est défectueuse
les brûlures représente 17% les
accidents domestiques
la surcharge des prises de courant
pouvant provoquer un court-circuit et
l'implantation anarchique des dites
prise dans une salle de bain tout le
monde s'en méfie mais plus de 200
personnes se laissent piéger chaque
année
l'utilisation de n'importe quoi placer
n'importe comment pour servir d'escabeau
les chutes représentent 43% des
accidents domestiques et
l'incompatibilité souvent fatale entre
la télévision et la table à repasser
surtout quand le programme et de choix
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire
avec plus de 7 millions d'accidents
annuelle ça devient plus dangereux de
vivre chez soi que de prendre la route
bref on trouve tout dans ce salon les
outils les idées les conseils la seule
chose que je n'ai pas vu toutefois c'est
le pinceau qui tient tout seul au
plafond quand on retire les chefs
j'espère maintenant football dernier
match du championnat de france de
première division cet après midi le
paris saint-germain en queue de
classement
jouer très gros contre marseille au parc
des princes dominique le glou marseille
au parc et voilà le public revenus 22
mille spectateurs 22 mille spectateurs
enthousiasmés par une série de dribbles
de klaus allofs ponctué d'un centre
malencontreusement détourné dans ses
filets par omar sène le psg menait 1-0
réagit bien l'ultime minute de la
première période rennes-auxerre simba
simba damanaki du gauche trompe poubelle
c'est l'égalisation qui met fin à une
série de cinq défaites d'affilée pour
les parisiens qui ont eu un peu de
chance cette fois un premier tir d'aloxe
s'écrasant sur la transversale
un second un peu plus tard de jean
pierre papin trouvant l'extérieur du
poteau droit de joël bats un psg qui en
fin de match pourtant répulsion la
décision tant les marseillais semblaient
fatigués par leur dure semaine
finale du tournoi de tennis de paris cet
hymne mayotte qui l'a emporté devant son
cap compatriote pardon américain lui
aussi brad gilbert entre mayotte et
gilberte 5e cette finale marathon chacun
des joueurs a repris le service de
l'autre maillot de serre wilbert craque
gilberte déconcentré mayotte prend
l'avantagé 4 jeux à 3 le tournant de
cette rencontre
brad gilbert ne parvient plus à
effectuer ses retours de service
pris de vitesse
gilberte s'écroule team mayotte beaucoup
plus calme commet moins de fautes que
son adversaire en fin de partie 2 6 6 3
7 5 6 7 6 3 victoire de team mayotte
après plus de trois heures et demie de
suspense oui de quoi sauter de joie au
chili aussi pardon j'ai gardé la bonne
nouvelle pour la fin cette antenne 2 qui
retransmettra l'année prochaine le
tournoi de tennis de roland garros et
certains matchs seront également
diffusés sur fr3 dans quelques instants
la carte météo va vous le prouvez
attention au brouillard pour demain
encore notamment sur la route
cela fait 48 heures maintenant que le
pays est soumis à ce régime et beaucoup
d'activités sont touchés circulation
routière bien entendu circulation
aérienne aussi et puis d'autres
l'activité plus inattendus
brouillard sur le stade ici le risque
majeur c'est d'emboutir son adversaire
au pire de se prendre un but sans
vraiment le voir arriver brouillard sur
la route
attention danger des vies sont en jeu
qu'à renvoie l'agencé ria matin 50
voitures un mort et 19 blessés cause
directe le brouillard deux conseils pour
conduire sans risque ça consiste à
utiliser les feux existants sur un
véhicule voir les feux de brouillard
sinon est équipé les feux de brouillard
vers l'avant il faut simplement penser à
les éteindre pour croiser enfin de ne
pas éblouir les feux rien il faut penser
à les utiliser pour être décelé par les
véhicules qui vous suivent voir qui vous
rattrape faut réduire sa vitesse
on ne dira jamais assez il faut
également maintenir des distances il est
hors de question de suivre un véhicule
aussi près afin de profiter de son
sillage et de son éclairage
il faut donc encore maintenir une
distance minimale de 50 mètres afin
d'éviter les accidents qui se produisent
en ce moment prudence et vigilance
la meilleure recette pour arriver au
bout du voyage voilà et maintenant le
tiercé les résultats du tiercé qui
secouerait cet après midi vous allez les
voir saint cyr sur votre écran 1450 de
francs dans l'ordre 1 3 8 et puis il y
avait également un quarté + tu as un
stère lui aussi 3534 francs pour le 1
place comme on dit le 3 le 8 et le 10
nous parlions à l'instant du brouillard
nous allons reparler avec la météo et je
vous signale un accident justement
conséquences sans aucun doute du
brouillard il ait lieu sur l'autoroute
du nord ce soir au niveau du département
de l'oise 36 véhicules se sont
caramboler il y aurait pour l'instant
une douzaine de blessés dont certains
très sérieux brouillard donc aujourd'hui
brouillard encore demain j'ose encore
demain oui mais nuages et pluie en prime
demain effectivement nous seront cernés
de main par des nuages qui arrivent de
toute part avec de la pluie dans leurs
bagages
voici donc une perturbation qui arrive
du nord-ouest une autre qui arrive du
sud ouest inutile de vous dire qu'il
n'ya pas un mais pas le moins
d'anticyclone pour arrêter ce
déferlement résultats demain à la
mi-journée nuages et pluie des pays de
loire au bassin parisien jusqu'à la
champagne ardenne après le passage de
cette perturbation y aura quelques
éclaircies sur la bretagne la normandie
et le nord pas de calais à la vente
cette zone perturbée de l'aquitaine à la
vendée au jura et aux vosges le ciel
restera couvert avec des brouillards qui
seront persistant nuages et pluie du
languedoc-roussillon aux alpes avec
quelques éclaircies toutefois dans le
midi et sur l'accord les températures
relève la tête sur la moitié nord c'est
à dire 9 degrés à lille reims et nancy 8
à strasbourg sur la moitié sud 12 à lyon
mais 19 ajaccio et demain lundi 9
novembre
pensez à théodore voilà nous y penserons
sans aucun doute le dernier journal ce
sera tout à l'heure en fin de programme
philippe gassot demain soir ici même
vous retrouverez henri sannier
quant à moi je l'espère je vous
retrouverai la semaine prochaine au
revoir excellente semaine
e